well you picked the right person at the
right time
you wouldn't want to be two days ago
because i got high and i was just too
all over
the place all right jennifer
yeah jennifer where'd you grow up where
are you from wisconsin
dairy farm what part of wisconsin uh
just below madison wisconsin
uh actually grew up um
and up in portage with my um my
regular mom and dad were up there
and at age five uh my
my mom my mom and divorced at
like three i've had a really treacherous
childhood but at five she dumped me off
at foster family on a dairy farm which i
stayed till 11.
is it that was a foster family yeah why
do you think your mom
did that because she because she
couldn't handle family
uh my sister my two sisters went to my
dad's
in in portage and she went and found
some
she joined the military and went to
germany
uh married my stepfather they couldn't
both be in otherwise they'd be separated
so she decided to get out
and follow them get jobs at different
me va hospitals and stuff while they
were going everywhere
which i've been a few places with them
here and there
how was your childhood with the foster
family it was pretty good but i
had a really adhd and a whole bunch of
stuff i had
i was a girl inside and and i
uh was starting to be bullied
uh calling a whole bunch of names and i
finally
became the bully and it was problem
problem problem until 11 where my foster
family couldn't take care of me
i got put into different institutions
after another
with a couple breaks with my stepfather
and mom trying to take me
but i was too much for them um
i mean i've been to fort knox and ohio
and hawaii
and stuff like that in texas
[Music]
but i on my 18th birthday right before
18 i turned
i got a graduated ged in that last
institution
and then on 18 um on my 18th birthday
they couldn't take me anymore at the
institution
so they got my sister in ohio and her
husband to accept me
so they sent me there on my 18th
birthday in 86.
um it's you know
and then there's a lot of drugs and
alcohol and
alcohol first and when did drugs and
alcohol come into the picture for you
well alcohol has been in my life all
along my
time my oh my dad was alcoholic there
was a
quite a few times and when i was young
when he gave it to my mom mom gave it to
me everything
wisconsin was he could even drink in the
bars with your
with your family as long as because the
real laws were
the bars weren't responsible if anything
happened in the bar
with the child or whatever if they're
drinking it was on them
now it's changed because of all the
drunk driving accidents
um you know
so at 18 and 86 i
really have went into alcohol in 89 i
died on it
in hawaii drinking buck every day
then i stopped and
met cocaine left hawaii
all in abrupt came here and it was
carrying cracks feed everything
and acid and a whole bunch of stuff and
got busted for
lsd in 91 and then i
i haven't been in trouble with a lot
since
so today you're living in the tenderloin
i live right on the edge of
um i live over on mason street i
shouldn't say that
uh i live over you know near uh union
square
okay but it's right at a block away from
hell right now right a block away from
crackville and all that stuff are you
living on the street or you're at home
no i gotta i got an apartment
okay how do you support yourself how do
you make money uh
disability
and uh do you have any contact with your
family still my mom and dad
that are dead or dead mom in 2005
dad in 2007 my mom left that inheritance
for my sisters and i
and it came through in 2007 and since
then
because i'm legally blind my sister
found a way to
get the the survivor benefits for me not
my stepfather
and uh ever since then i've had extra a
little bit
to help me and where i live now i pay 50
percent of my income
what's been the hardest part of being
trans
for you ah i haven't had as much
problems as most
girls i've heard about you know getting
harassed
because of it probably because i appear
myself streetwise
and i i will beat somebody up if they
thought
you know screw with me um and i
i bring that parrots with me because i
don't want somebody
punking me out because then i'll have to
get into it and
gets me out a lot of stuff i've been in
a lot of projects to get crack
and and uh seen a lot of stuff i don't
you know i got extreme ptsd
some stuff i've seen some horror stuff
that nobody needs to see
what's the worst thing you've seen i
mean i've seen pillars
i don't need to say exactly what but
i've seen a lot of different variations
of killings right in front of me i've
had guns put on my
right after that to scope me out to see
if i would say something or something
i seconds away from them killing me too
but my aura is different you know that's
the way i carry myself
and plus i have a higher power that has
been helping me
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years
living on the streets and stuff well
it's a lesson of life you know you know
you don't snitch you don't
you don't uh you don't steal from
anybody
um um
everybody has that lesson about you know
stealing from stores and things that can
handle it and stuff like that
but uh copper piping or whatever
um that's why i stopped heroin in the
night
early 90s um i did it for
like a year and uh
got to the point where i broke a
mercedes sl window for a leather jacket
that was in the back that's pretty much
i think that's the only thing i stole
from a person
um that's probably why i got a lot of
good karma and crack is your drug today
no it's off and on what what what are
your drugs now
yeah uh lsd
kraken meth but you've tried them all
oh yeah yeah just
just dmt and a few others molly and
stuff like that i haven't done
and you you were born this way you
believe right it's not something that
happened to you as a kid or anything
like that
oh yeah you knew this since since you
were a young child
yeah kind of and and i had you know
different signs of it and i had a
partner in 91
to 2 right before 2001.
um um he picked me up on poke street
when i was hustling my ass for whatever
i could to get more
and i've done a lot of that um so you've
done some sex work as well
yeah and um you still do
well in the right in the right mo i
haven't done it for a while but
in the right most place i would um
but this guy picked me up he didn't ever
have sex with me he didn't want that
you know he just wanted a partner kind
of
he was he ended up being a part owner of
a really famous gay bar in the city
um and uh
i could have done this transition with
him i don't know why i didn't
i guess cards played the way they did
i ended up leaving him for a woman
to try that way once i tried it i made
an honest effort to go that way
um you know
it's a shame that i left them it wasn't
about
getting inheritance from or anything
because i probably do have something
there i just never went
and i don't need it because of the way i
left them
and um but he took me
around the world to like bali
on india um uh in a whole bunch of
places in the sun
over there um but never had sex
and now i know why i mean i was in the
psych ward when i was with her
at one point in the same hospital he
died
in and later
she it's almost like she showed me on
purpose
just to stab at me because of how
you know because when she when she found
out that i
uh when i first started dating her
um she found out i was going home to him
and sleeping in the same bed and she's
like you got to move in with me as
always abruptly leaving him
and and uh she did a lot of
she's she's a really famous person here
on the web
six figures at one time and i never paid
rent with her either
um and um
you know it was interesting i learned a
lot
you know every time i relapsed i had
many years clean here
two weeks relapse many years clean
i got cleaned in 2000 1994
uh for four and a half years ended up a
hep c
um from
from tattoo work is right i could have
had
aids or anything you know that i found
out that's why i
uh got uh he never had sex with me
because that's what he died from hiv
complications he never told me and i
probably would have never met him
i left them if he ever would have told
me that
um dear friends
i have lots of friends but they're all
in recovery and i don't
you know i'm starting to that's what
keeps me getting relapsing sometimes i
you know i used to have a network of
friends and sponsors that
they called me i called them now
everybody
sits there and doing their own thing i
hardly ever ever have anybody call me
anymore
so it's like that little loneliness
thing you know are they really my
friends
and the thing that's the thing that
makes me want to move to a different
area
to get new friends that don't have
my rec long record of in and out of the
rooms
because a lot of my friends have decades
sober or whatever
and they don't get it that i'm still
alive
and haven't got it yet and they don't
treat me like a newcomer coming back
like their the program says you're
supposed to and that's pretty much what
i'm
thinking about right now you know some
right now i'm having a little off and
off again you know on-again
fun yeah what's been the best time of
your life
oh probably when i was with ben
it was been the roughest time
during the street life i mean in 2015
you asked me something about trans
i was at the next door shelter on and
doing sex work and stuff and
uh i ended up being
uh getting pissed off at a crack dealer
for ripping me off for five bucks
and i went back on them the next day and
i told him you can't do that you gotta
oh you owe me and
he's hustled tried to get money out of
me and
he said no no no and then he started to
bust something out
but give me a little piece i'm like you
know you have to pay for your mistake
and then he'd
realize i was serious and then he sucker
punched me and ran and he ran into a
pole
and i got on and beat the hell out of
him
and i could have been killed that night
because i was
just in a position where they all had
guns and
a lot of drugs and there was a drug
corner and you don't do that [ __ ]
uh they laughed at first because they
never seen a trans
like take out a guy like that
and uh then somebody came in and kicked
me in the head
and my head got a cut here and
almost lost my eye and then
when i came to i was getting punched
and kicked like i was being jumped into
a gang
so this is another lesson in life that i
knew
knew from the gut you know it's like a
street corner if you can walk away from
this
just do so i walked away bloody and
walked up to the shelter and
uh and uh did the
um you know ammo stuff there
and a couple days later and that ended
up earning me street cred with drug
dealers
what what advice would you give to a
young trans
person that's considering
well to do it do it go with your heart
and and just follow yourself you know
where you need to go
and and just make sure you have
straight around you know the lessons you
learn about protection before you
transition you got to keep that you know
because it's like
if you look like somebody you can get
you know
take advantage of or killed um
they'll do that you gotta put that
energy away from you
um because i don't bring that towards me
and it doesn't
come towards me i've hardly had anybody
try to do anything again so i've carried
thousands of dollars on me and nobody's
come at me because i appear
like i don't have anything um
i just you know
i just don't you know i just learned so
many lessons i could be here for three
and a half hours just telling the whole
thing
so this could be a two-parter if you
need it
um so
all right jennifer well thank you so
much for talking with me and good luck
with wherever you go from here okay
thank you
you